طبعا من اليوم الاول للعدوان الصهيوني على
قطاع غزه ونزح الكثير من الاهالي الى
مراكز الاواء التي هي غير
امنه قصف الاحتلال الصهيوني العديد من
مسابق شمال قطاع غزه حتى يعني احصا
الاحصائيه الاخيره في مساجد بيت حنون مثلا
لم يتبقى اي مسجد في بيت حنون الجميع
مساجد بيت حنون هدمت كذلك مساجد الشمال
حتى يعني ونصلي او نحيي صلاه الجماعه في
مراكز الاواء الغير امنه
عندنا صعوبه وكانت ايضا من الصعوبات التي
تواجهنا ضاظ الاهالي النازحين في داخل
مراكز الاواء ايضا المراكز غير امنه عندما
نسمع باستهداف مراكز الاواء يتخوف كثير من
الناس النزول الى الملعب او نزول ارض
المركز للصلاه فيه وذلك بسبب انعدام الامن
انعدام الطمانينه في مراكز الاواء التي
تستهدف الاحتلال الصهيوني نعاني من اقامه
صلاه الجمعه في داخل مراكز الاواء بسبب
هذا العدوان الغاشم على قطاعنا الحبيب
نعاني ايضا من تجهيز الاماكن او مصليات
لجمع الناس حتى يصلوا في يوم الجمعه او في
اي صلاه مفروضه بسبب الخوف الذي يعونه
بسبب الاستهداف الغاشم لمراكز الاواء او
بجوار مراكز الاواء ولا سما يعني ارتقى
كثير من الشهداء في داخل مراكز الاواء
وارتقى ايضا في محيط مراكز الاواء عدد
كبير من الشهداء فيبقى عنصر الامن مفقود
عند كثير من الاهالي يصلون في غرفهم يحيون
صلاه الصلاه
المفروضه